[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy viajaremos al pasado para
entender por qué eeuu aún mantiene un
sistema electoral tan diferente al del
resto del mundo el primer presidente en
ser elegido fue george washington en
1789 luego de que un año atrás fuera
ratificada la constitución de los eeuu
un país que por entonces estaba
conformado por 13 estados antiguas
colonias británicas ubicadas a lo largo
de la costa este de su actual territorio
la mayoría de países del mundo cuenta
con un sistema de voto popular tan
sencillo como si un candidato obtiene
una mayor cantidad de votos es elegido
presidente pero lo que cuesta entender
en eeuu es como hace cuatro años cuando
hillary clinton superó al donald trump
por cerca de tres millones de papeletas
aún así perdió la presidencia
la explicación está basada en ese
sistema que viene desde los tiempos de
george washington llamado colegio
electoral un modelo antiguo que de
acuerdo con alexander que y ser profesor
de historia y política social de la
universidad de harvard
no es ningún secreto que la esclavitud
desempeña un papel en el diseño original
de este sistema de elecciones
presidenciales según case art la fórmula
de que cada estado pudiera estar
representado en el congreso por su
número de habitantes y en consecuencia
tener una mayor o menor voz a la hora de
elegir un presidente tuvo un factor
decisivo en el pasado por el número de
esclavos es ampliamente conocido que
estados del sur como georgia alabama
texas tennessee durante el siglo 19
contaron en su censo con una gran
mayoría de esclavos africanos esta suma
de esclavos era crucial para que los
estados sureños pudieran tener una mayor
representación en la cámara y el senado
de hecho la fórmula decía que tres
quintas partes de los esclavos que se
tuvieran se contaban como parte
poblacional para tener mayor cantidad de
votos electorales de manera que los
estados sureños los más esclavistas
según kaiser tuvieron una influencia
desproporcionada en la elección de los
presidentes advertidos los estados del
norte de esta ventaja sureña en 1816 se
llevó al congreso por primera vez
un proceso para cambiar de sistema
electoral por uno de voto nacional
popular pero de acuerdo con que izar en
su libro porque aún tenemos los colegios
electorales las protestas de varios
senadores sureños boicotearon la
propuesta y la razón es simple no les
convenía porque perderían representación
y número para elegir presidentes un
ejemplo fueron las elecciones del año
1856 cuando recién se había creado el
partido republicano en ese año el
candidato republicano era jones y
freemont y su adversario era el
demócrata james buchanan para la época
los republicanos buscaban abolir la
esclavitud mientras que los demócratas
buscaban expandir la los resultados
marcaron la evidente polarización entre
los intereses del sur y del norte los
estados sureños se colorearon de azul y
eligieron por mayoría a buchanan para
continuar con la esclavitud mientras que
los estados del norte como nueva york y
ohio se pintaron de rojo al votar por
frei mont pero no alcanzaron la mayoría
del colegio electoral pocos años después
en 1861 estalló la guerra de secesión el
conflicto más sangriento y la crisis
constitución
y moral más profunda que ha vivido en
los eeuu en toda su historia en esos
cuatro años de guerra abraham lincoln
fungió como el presidente republicano
que lideró a los estados del norte en su
cruzada contra los estados del sur al
derrotar a los sureños lincoln puso fin
a la esclavitud en todo el país pero con
todo y su victoria no pudo contener las
políticas federales de los blancos
redentores podría decirse que en el
campo electoral el resultado de la
guerra favoreció a los sureños porque al
dejar de existir la fórmula de los tres
quintos de afros esclavizados se pasó a
contabilizar a los cinco quintos es
decir a mayor cantidad de afros
liberados mayor cantidad de votos
electorales y se pensaría que los
afroamericanos liberados que ahora
podían votar saldrían a las urnas a
elegir presidentes con políticas anti
raciales y de igualdad pero la verdad es
que no los dejaban votar según que dicen
estos afros volvieron a ser privados de
sus derechos a pesar de la decimoquinta
enmienda de 1870 que expresaba la
libertad al voto sin reparar en la
a color o condición de servidumbre pero
en estados que fueron tan privativos de
la libertad racial como alabama la
policía no dejaba votar a los negros así
tuvieran el derecho y de esta forma los
estados del sur y sus regímenes de
supremacía blanca aumentaron su número
de votos electorales sin ver afectados
sus intereses políticos sólo hasta un
siglo después en la década en 1960 se
contó con un cambio significativo
gracias a la proclamación de los
derechos civiles afroamericanos la nueva
ley de derechos electorales obligó a los
estados a abolir la segregación y
permitir el voto de los
afroestadounidenses y dicho esto
resucitó un proceso político motivado
por los republicanos para que eeuu
cambiará su sistema electoral por uno en
el que primará el voto nacional un
proceso que según kaiser estuvo
marginado por décadas por la actitud
inflexible del sur y su peso político
para bloquear una enmienda
constitucional en el congreso tal como
se presumía en 1970 llegó al pleno del
senado la resolución para cambiar de
sistema de colegio electoral a sistema
de voto popular
pero el 75% de los senadores del sur
votaron en contra de este proyecto y
como anunció el senador james salen de
alabama en 1969 el colegio electoral es
una de las pocas salvaguardias políticas
que quedan en el sur en síntesis para
alexander keyser el colegio electoral
probablemente habría sido cambiado si la
política racial no hubiera sido tan
airada en el siglo 19 del siglo 20 pero
lo cierto es que eeuu aún en el siglo 21
ha puesto en descubierto que el tema
racial divide y que hasta que no haya un
consenso no se podrá cambiar la forma en
que eligen a sus presidentes hasta aquí
llegamos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
muchas gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en france
24 punto com
[Música]